una convención nacional casi desierta la
crisis del cobi 19 ha transformado un
evento habitualmente abarrotado donde el
partido se reúne en torno a su líder en
una transmisión virtual pero para los
demócratas que quieren nominar a joe
biden y kamala harris lo importante no
es el formato sino que se llegue a la
casa blanca
el futuro de nuestra democracia está en
juego el futuro en nuestra economía está
en juego el futuro de nuestro planeta
está en juego bagua planeta durante este
primer día michelle obama habló en
nombre de joe vaivén la ex primera dama
dijo que en bailén escuchará y protegerá
a todos los estadounidenses y atacó a
donald trump
solbes honest en así que permítanme ser
lo más honesta y clara que pueda donald
trump es el presidente equivocado para
nuestro país ha tenido tiempo más que
suficiente para demostrar que puede
hacer el trabajo pero claramente está
superado no puede enfrentar este momento
simplemente no puede ser quién
necesitamos que sea para nosotros wind y
mtv fue así
mariana fabbiani vaina
muchos de ustedes me conocen saben que
digo lo que siento
saben que odio la política pero también
saben que me preocupo por esta nación
valdés nation
soy fitch won se si se llevan algo de
mis palabras en esta noche que sea esto
si creen que las cosas no pueden
empeorar
créanme pueden hacerlo y lo harán en day
with la convención comenzó con una
declaración de los hermanos de george
floyd cuya muerte provocó protestas
masivas contra el racismo un tributo a
las víctimas negras asesinadas por la
policía
todos deberían estar vivos hoy así que
nos toca a nosotros seguir luchando por
justicia web e ideales de dubai then
apareció en un vídeo grabado hablando
con un líder negro sobre cómo poner fin
al racismo los demócratas intentaron
sacar lo mejor de este formato mostrando
a personas de 50 estados algunos de los
cuales compartían sus problemas durante
el mandato de trump incluso varios
republicanos compartieron estos vídeos
diciendo que se han cruzado líneas para
preservar otro mandato de donald trump
-